hello and welcome to this video playing
sm-3 m Oh actually sorry hahaha ah it's
dead Sarah well now I have to play the
the pills defense I somehow felt like we
already had seaforth I would it be the
groom friend this is crazy I game oh my
god now i know i have some some opening
line where have no idea what's going on
ah presume
I think you have to take and play 94 I
know it looks very strange but if i'm
not mistaken this is really correct I've
looked at this last year's channel for
white actually oh my god g5 ok check ok
it looks kind of ok
I'm not happy I mean I never wanted this
position but it's not so bad here okay I
mean check check this is check it's not
so bad can I do this maybe try to snatch
the h2porn it's a bit cheeky but why not
exactly so I did win this porn but he
has rook age one coming so maybe here
should p.m. if it goes ok ch.1 yeah my
development is not great it really isn't
try to not use too much time it is kind
of uncomfortable ok 94 maybe this is
covered or is he trying to know thinking
Bishop is six just like cool maybe this
is possible that not doesn't seem to be
yeah well I'm not sure why exactly what
he has pretty decent compensation here
night f8 Mamie and night
night if 8 9 to 26 not okay you can go
actually here which phone and then I've
not g6 ad is a pretty good compensation
yeah what can you do check so do i have
to take and not strictly necessary maybe
i can go here or to d8 actually i can go
to the ATM I can then you can take angle
Naja for okay okay so maybe I have to
take am not much fun to take scott
Bishop d3 coming it's very difficult to
to play this this kind of position for
win maybe it still this one trying to
win it's very ambitious may be wrong
okay well this is this is not really
threatening much maybe I check somewhere
yeah he probably threatens to take the
ship g6 we should be seven when you get
rook h7 coming oh my this is not good
yeah cannot I cannot win this position
problem
probably not
time boarding
now timewise I'm in trouble trouble here
position is ok I think
yeah he had this head compensation for
all this at least he got something got
some compensation
decimating record king kings at these
six I can check check I don't know I
just don't see you don't see it here
mm k do I do here take it takes you too
long and play yeah okay pretty much have
to him check
check check draw our third name or
removable trying to win on time position
is totally dead of course check check
yeah just not include blitz at its best
check check yeah and you will tell you
check right Kim check glad for a fix on
time yeah okay this is just this ancient
time control what can you do yeah but
it's it's kind of it's kind of
frustrating because it just blundered
upon hear it it is he has compensation
for that I mean it's really difficult to
get this position organized and of
course I have well I'm not were so
anything I'm the only one trying to win
but it's difficult to do here it is just
it is just to draw course which gap and
up with this time check yeah i'm a poor
nurse at i cannot win this is still far
too actor
cuz I hang out and well it is a draw but
it's also five minutes without
incremented it takes a while to get this
position sorted always a little bit
annoying to see Evan name in there no
okay so yeah not much the same he had he
continued for the continued to win on
time them I don't really know about this
opening I think I think this is actually
a non line but and I never ever wanted
to get to go there check check and no
one takes time this kind of position if
you if you don't know stuff but yeah I
was kind of okay time was I did sense
it's just uncomfortable to play yeah
okay well thanks for watching